two  assists away from a triple double they  double them  on the wing porter taking it home  wow dad likes that one  we're here with the wind-up and the  finish  over montrez harold the reigning sixth  men of the year  here's jamal murray with the reaction  jokic  good stunt there by marcus morris shot  clock at nine murray takes it and tried  to jam and was rejected at the rim it  was  almost saved by beverly kawhi leonard is  doing it all what a defensive play well  jamal murray was trying to  catch a body here look at this oh my  goodness  it looks like he blocked it with one of  those fingers of  what a beautiful block here it's like  he's got a baseball glove on  he blocked it with his middle finger  that is amazing  do you see that yeah he blocked it with  his middle